bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 c'est parti pour le
sommaire football poissy a joué ce
week-end en nationale 2 contre sainte
geneviève et les pisciacais ont
enregistré une nouvelle défaite le score
2 buts à 1 conséquence son entraîneur de
l'équipe laurent fournier a été démis de
ses fonctions les détails dans cette
émission
football l'équipe de conflans va
affronter vitry dimanche prochain pour
le compte du 6e tour de la coupe de
france nous aurons la chance de recevoir
l'entraîneur et le capitaine de l'équipe
dans cette émission interview à suivre
découverte aujourd'hui tv 68 vous fera
découvrir le disc golf un sport hybride
entre l'ultimate et le golf
une session était organisée à lille de
loisirs de 50 ans de vie il faut qu
sedan ce un magazine l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres nous
allons parler des jo de 2024 et plus
précisément du site éphémère de
versailles qui accueillera l'équitation
l'emplacement est presque confirmé à
100% par les instances mais des
pressions politiques et du monde de
l'équitation pourrait faire pencher la
balance du côté de lamotte beuvron
cette semaine des experts vont se
déplacer sur les 400 hectares du parc
équestre situé entre orléans et vierzon
le coup est notamment évoquée versa
écouterez 27,3 millions d'euros et celui
de la motte entre 10 et 12 millions on
écoute le maire de versailles françois
de mazières sur le sujet politiquement
parlant bianco qui est vrai et on peut
le comprendre
d'autres et pourquoi chez eux donc ce
bateau mais on n'était pas vraiment une
réunion à la préfecture a priori
versailles où les lieux aux épreuves
d'équitation
en football on jouait ce week-end sur
les terrains de national 2 rien ne va
plus pour quoi si les pisciacais se sont
inclinés 2 1 sur leur pelouse contre
sainte-geneviève une défaite au goût
amer qui les enfonce encore un peu plus
au classement des images d'astrid
bergère à montage de xavier gens c'était
le match à ne pas perdre pour l'as
poissy derniers du classement les
yvelinois recevait sainte geneviève pour
un derby francilien
malmenés en première période les joueurs
de laurent fournier encaisse un but à
zéro ce sera le score à la pause la
première mi temps
pas grand chose si ce n'est que pas
beaucoup d'occasions sans créer une ont
fait une erreur sur le côté un centre
on est attentif on prend ce but en
deuxième période fois ci revient sur le
terrain avec plus de combativité
l'épicier qui se procurent des occasions
et arrive à obtenir un penalty sur cette
main fabien raddas marque fois ci
revient au score un but partout à la 69e
minute de jeu mais sainte geneviève
marque sur l'une de ses seules occasions
de la seconde période de 2 à 1 ce sera
le score final
sentiment d'injustice parce que parce
qu'on a plus d'eau casey que je pense
que sur la deuxième mi-temps au mérite
on mérite au moins le point du match nul
ce résultat n'arrange pas poissy le club
s'enfonce au classement l'épicé qui sont
toujours bons derniers de la poule avec
déjà sept défaites
c'est rageant faut serrer les dents je
pense que même si on perd aujourd'hui
c'est de bonne augure dans le sens où on
fait une prestation correcte il ya des
matches où on fait des prestations
vraiment lamentable là aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut
reprocher à tous les acteurs de l'équipe
de poids si je sais pas grand chose
aurait prononcé après savez le football
ça va vite
c'est moi je suis là pour entraîner pour
faire progresser un groupe c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué mais voilà on
s'accroche
voici tentera de se relancer lors de la
prochaine journée contre l'équipe
réserve de caen le 7 novembre domicile
laurent fournier ne sera pas sur le banc
l'entraîneur a été démis de ses
fonctions le lendemain de cette défaite
contre sainte geneviève
comme vous l'avez entendu dans leurs
reportages précédents cette défaite aura
été fatale à l'entraîneur de poissy
laurent fournier l'ancien coach du psg a
été démis de ses fonctions après ce
résultat enregistré contre sainte
geneviève le club a obtenu une seule
victoire cette saison sur tapis vert
face à granville et pointe à la dernière
place de nationale 2 le président du
club olivier cv zut planche déjà sur son
remplaçant la piste d'un entraîneur de
la région parisienne est évoquée en
attendant un intérimaire sera nommé ce
lundi en interne dont une nouvel
entraîneur devrait être dévoilé dans la
semaine dans l'autre rencontre de
national de versailles s'est imposé ce
week end sur la pelouse de guingamp et
versailles et l'ont emporté 2-1 avec
cette précieuse victoire à l'extérieur
les versets s'éloigne un peu de la zone
de relégation ils sont actuellement 10e
sur ses équipes engagées en nationale 3
le fc mantois s'est incliné 3 à 2 sur
son terrain contre aubervilliers
dans l'autre rencontre évinoise les murs
ont également perdu 3 1 face à ivry
au classement les mureaux sont bons
derniers avec zéro victoire depuis le
début de la saison le fc mantois et lui
à 10e sur 14 dans le championnat de
régionale 2 trappe s'est imposé 1 à 0
sur le terrain de parisienne à
l'extérieur lors de la 4e journée des
trappistes coachée par hicham et redit
débute parfaitement cette saison 2 r2
ils sont actuellement co-leader du
championnat avec trois victoires et une
défaite
une division en dessous dans le
championnat de régionale 3 seniors
maurepas se reprend après une défaite
contre l'équipe réserve de versailles
les murs parisiens se sont brillamment
imposés avec un festival offensif ce
dimanche contre les ulis le score quatre
buses à dieu cette victoire permet aux
yvelinois d'occuper la deuxième place du
classement de cette poule a avec un
point de retard sur le leader versailles
on écoute les réactions au micro de tv
forcément très content d'avoir gagné
donc 4 2 on a fait un bon match
une manne au score rapidement et voilà
c'est important gagner à domicile c'est
l'objectif de prendre tous les points en
ce début de saison constance le contrat
est rempli trois matches trois victoires
à la maison donc voilà c'est plus
important pour l'instant tout le monde
sauf par exemple pour les autres on
essaye de jouer au ballon
franchement c'est bien même à
l'entraînement tout le monde tout le
monde bosse dur c'est très bien et que
du positif pour l'instant on continue à
parler football ce sera l'un des matches
ne pas manquer ce week-end dans les
yvelines en coupe de france conflent
affrontera à vitry ce dimanche dans un
match qui s'annonce très équilibré les
deux équipes évoluent en terrain pour
nous parler de ce rendez vous nous avons
la chance de recevoir sur ce plateau le
coach car le brizault priso et le
capitaine anderson diguiny bonsoir
messieurs alors tout simplement est-ce
que vous avez vous êtes trop descendu de
ce 5e tour de coupe de france avec cette
victoire contrôles menés aux tirs au but
bien sûr parce qu'il a fallu préparer le
match de championnat qui a eu lieu hier
donc se replonger tout de suite dans
notre vie quotidienne
donc oui on est dit on s'est vite
replongé dans le match 2 de championnat
et passer à autre chose par rapport à la
qualification compte rooney anderson
vous confirmez ça fait vraiment été
assez rapide
on a pris le temps de savourer le le
dimanche soir et après à partir du
lendemain en avant entraînements et tout
de suite pas on est passé de la coupe de
france au championnat d'air est ce que
vous avez pu récupérer bien récupéré
après cette rencontre
oui parce que la science d'une
handicapée a permis de pouvoir récupérer
le coach lamine séances sont conséquents
après à partir du mercredi
c'est reparti sur des chapeaux de roues
alors c'est un 5e tour de coupe de
france
est-ce que vous avez quand même fêter ça
oui on l'a fêtée dans le bca modération
avec modération comme un vestiaire comme
vous l'a dit après des lendemains au
travail comme la après si bien dit
henderson des moments on a fait une
séance de récupération mais aussi pour
se projeter sur la semaine par rapport
au mal donc d'hier et puis voilà on n'a
pas eu le temps de
de cogiter parce que on a nos objectifs
aussi à remplir et non voilà est-ce que
vous avez déjà le sentiment d'avoir
écrit l'une des plus belles pages
peut-être de l'histoire du club pas
encore pas encore parce que je pense
qu'il faut passer ce tour-là et après à
partir de là on pourra dire qu'on a fait
quelque chose de sympa et on sait que
l'aventuré va s'arrêter un moment donné
mais si on peut la prolonger le plus
longtemps possible de vendre pas s'en
priver
peut-être pas peut-être pas je t'ai dit
la dernière fois votre collaboratrice on
va peut-être aller au stade de france
anderson qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous maintenant il
fallait tout de suite passer à autre
chose très rapidement se reconcentrer
sur cette rencontre importante pour
l'histoire du club
pas nécessairement entre les patins dans
le vestiaire avec les autres joueurs de
marquer l'histoire du club
oui bah c'est un objectif pour pour les
joueurs pour nous mais je pense pour le
coach après on essaie de prendre les
matches les uns après les autres on
c'est pour ça que tout de suite on est
passé vraiment du match de la coupe de
france au championnat mais c'est clair
que si on arrive à passer autour de
souviennent dimanche contre vitry je
pense qu'à partir de là on pourra dire
qu'on a marqué les esprits du club mais
pour l'instant ni encore je rappelle le
score du week end 0 à 0 à domicile
contre la garenne colombes
ah bon score pas forcément
alors non c'est un score de parité il ya
une opposition de style contre deux
équipes qui avaient des objectifs des
objectifs pardon différents voilà
tactiquement l'équipe
visiteuse a joué son coup à fond on a
essayé de trouver les solutions
on n'a pas réussi après c'est bien on
prend pas de but on ne perd pas donc
c'est très bien pour le moment et de son
côté vitry a perdu 1 0 face à noisy le
grand pantin davantage pas forcément
alors il ya en bois le verre à moitié
vide ou à moitié plein la série s'est
arrêtée pour eux puisque ce sont des
promus comme nous ils ont gagné tous
leurs matches de championnat tout en
match de coupe de france excepté un
match nul qu'ils ont vidés au penalty
quand une série s'arrête c'est compliqué
de faire relancer à la machine en
revanche on peut se dire qu'il ya une
bête blessée qui a nous voir aussi donc
voilà on n'a pas peur de nous ils n'ont
pas peur de nous ça va être une belle
affiche de championnat ressemble au
championnat pendant le coupe de france
de deux équipes en airain lapsus est
révélateur c'est un lapsus révélateur
effectivement on n'est pas dans la même
poule mais voilà après on aborde le ce
match avec sérénité tout simplement ou
confirmé en personne mais qui peut vous
connaissez bien vous les joueurs parce
que votre coach a l'air de les connaître
parfaitement
est ce que vous les connaissez non du
taux après ça c'est vraiment le rôle du
coach mon nez les joueurs en acteur on
prend les matches les uns après les
autres après c'est vraiment dur au sort
du coach d'analysé l'équipe qu'on va
rencontrer le week-end mais c'est vrai
que au delà d'un match de coupe de
france ça va ressembler comme un match
de championnat pour nos jeunes équipes
de notre championnat
maintenant ça reste quand même un match
de coupe et on va passer
quels seront les recettes justement à
votre avis andersen
moi je pense que le match on devrait
l'aborder comme tous les matches sont se
mettre une pression particulière
en effet en et en faisant en sorte de
respecter nos principes de jeu et puis à
partir de là je pense que ça devrait
bien se passer
est-ce que ça va jouer finalement au
mental peut être entre deux équipes qui
se ressemblent on vous l'avait dit un
karl priso est-ce que ça va jouer avant
tout au mental c'est un match de coupe
de france ça n'a rien à voir tout
championnat alors pour reprendre
anderson c
il ya forcément une approche différente
parce qu'il ya des conséquences par
rapport aux résultats puisque la
compétition s'arrête pour une des deux
équipes
ensuite oui bah ça c'est toujours mon
talent de toute façon coq et enfin ça ne
se jouera pas comment talent puisque on
prépare le match techniquement
tactiquement
après je pense que j'aurais pas beaucoup
de travail à faire pour aller puiser au
fond de la motivation
et puis oui il faudra mettre les
ingrédients tous les ingrédients pour
pouvoir passer le match on nous donnera
on va pas nous le donner donc il
faudrait chercher
voilà justement on voit sur ces images
cette communion avec les supporters
après une séance de tirs au but
est ce coup travaillé les tirs au but
cette semaine à l'entraînement ça vous
allez travailler à l'as la séance avant
le match en coupe effectivement on fait
une petite séance est ce qu'on peut
appeler ça un travail
c'est une séance de penalty on le fait
de façon décontractée après faut savoir
que quand on est en compétition c'est
plus de façon décontractée mais c'est ça
qu'il faut amener aussi donc il faut
sortir le meilleur d'eux en justement
en faisant abstraction de l'événement
est aussi de l'environnement et donc on
fait ça aussi à l'entraînement les
choses on les fait de façon décontractée
des relations j'ai posé la question à
tous les deux qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour la rencontre victor
victoire il ya que ça de toute façon
qu'est ce qu'on peut espérer d'être avec
vos supporters évidemment merci à tous
les deux d'être passé à sur ce plateau
bon courage pour ce 6e tour de coupe de
france sont ainsi pas vous recevoir dans
les prochaines semaines avec deux
nouvelles victoires et pourquoi pas le
stade de france en fin d'année on verra
ça à merci c'est l'une des performances
du week-end dans la ville de tours les
minimes de l'entente athlétique de saint
quentin en yvelines sont devenues
championnes de france face à 45 équipes
qualifiées pour cette finale nationale
elles ont obtenu ce résultat et 475
points avec 20 points d'avancé sur
clermont athlétisme auvergne
le dernier titre de champion de france
du club daté de 2009 à dreuilhe on ouvre
maintenant une page rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir à
réaliser une belle performance sur le
terrain du stade domontois les plaisirs
oies se sont imposés 31 à 7 et
continuent leur remontée au classement
et sont actuellement 6e du championnat
avec un bilan de 3 victoires et 3
défaites
matches disputés en fédérale 3 dans la
poule une bilan mitigé pour les illinois
l'entente maisons laffitte saint germain
poissy s'est imposé 23 20 face à evreux
ce dimanche dans l'autre rencontre où
ils s'inclinent 28 à 17 face à caen au
classement le mlsgp toujours leader de
la poule le club douilles et lui bon
dernier du championnat
toujours dans le championnat de fédérale
3 dans la poule 2 ce dimanche en plus
d'une victoire en équipe réserve hershey
s'est imposée 47 à 17 sur le terrain de
soissons lors de la 6e journée
on écoute justement pierre chevalier le
responsable communication du club de
versailles à ce petit jeu là avec les
les résultats inattendus
les bleu et blanc prennent la première
place de la poule 2 ce qui est assez
assez notable qui n'étaient pas
forcément dans les plans de début de
saison pour la suite
avec peut-être une suspension des
saisons pour les fédérale 2 et fédérale
3 nous verrons si le fait d'occuper
cette première place c'est de bonne
augure pour la suite et la fin de la
saison
comme chaque lundi c'est désormais
l'heure de notre interview express
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur
philippe sella l'ancien joueur de rugby
finalistes de la coupe du monde 1995 et
champion de france en 82 et a88 nous
l'avons rencontré lors d'une partie de
golf golf de feucherolles regarder
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé le rugby parce que mon
père a joué jusqu'à quarante deux ans
donc quand j'étais bébé
j'étais déjà sur sur les terrains
meilleur souvenir c'est compliqué dans
une longue carrière mais je vais parler
de la demi finale de la coupe du monde
tout ce qui s'est passé avant pendant et
après pourquoi parce que c'est une
demi-finale la première coupe du monde
elle est gagnée contre l'australie ce
match je pense qu'il est extraordinaire
il ya eu une préparation qui a été très
très dur parce qu'on l'avait joué un
match contre les fidji juste auparavant
qui avait pas été formidable et donc
jacques fouroux nous avait mis pas mal
de points sur les i pour se remettre en
question et puis après on a fêté la
demi-finale entre nous d'une manière
sage mais voilà l'image s'étaient tous
les joueurs au milieu du terrain après
le match en train de chanter quelques
chansons basques avec les amis basques
qui était dans l'équipe de france
les objectifs je suis engagé dans l'est
avec le club de rugby d'agen cessé de
pouvoir rester en top 14
évidemment c'est d'avoir une bonne santé
de rencontrer du monde et que le coc
vide on ne sera plus fort que lui
pourquoi en effet ne puisse y avoir
toujours beaucoup de mouvement et devait
la rencontre on continue à parler à au
rugby et coup de projecteur sur le rc 78
le club est actuellement 6e du
championnat de division honneur les
joueurs saint quentinois affiche un
bilan d'une victoire et une défaite
depuis le début de la saison pour nous
parler du club nous recevons sur ce
plateau maxime poudrier joueurs au sein
de l'équipe et jacques moreau preco
président on peut le dire de nuire ces
70 avec lionel garrigues un bilan d'une
victoire une défaite c'est un bilan
satisfaisant président s'était tenue à
l'extérieur donc on se dit que
finalement c'est pas mal d'avoir gagné
un malheureusement on n'a pas pu jouer
on n'a pas pu jouer le deuxième match
qui était chez nous contre clichy à
cause de joueurs des équipes adverses
qui est qu'ils avaient le cou vide
donc oui deux matches à l'extérieur une
victoire c'est plutôt bien ça plutôt
bien bon après on a eu une défaite assez
lourde par xo qui qu'ils étaient plus
forts que nous ce jour là très
clairement donc confirmé maxime oui oui
tout à fait c'est vrai que deux matches
pour tirer un bilan c'est un petit peu
un petit peu tôt on travaille bien on a
eu une victoire à l'extérieur le match à
la maison tu peux pas jouer et puis oui
la défaite à paris xe où il était plus
fort que nous après où je pense qu'on en
a tiré quand même des bonnes choses on a
réussi quand même à s'approcher de leur
niveau je pense sur quelques temps forts
du match des deux côtés
je confirme tout à vous qui êtes au sein
de la structure depuis quelques années
jusqu'à rugby en tout cas et puis
maintenant de l'union europe by 178 qui
a fusions des deux mon team retenue et
le sky le sky rugby comment vous
vous sentez vous dans cette équipe cette
année est ce que vous sentez l'équipe
est très très bien je trouve qu'on a
beaucoup de potentiel il ya beaucoup de
joueurs avec lesquels j'ai joué en
catégorie jeunes quand il y avait une
entente 50 à montigny à l'époque donc ça
fait plaisir de retrouver de retrouver
cette personne là à une bonne ambiance
on s'entend très bien le groupe est
assez jeune fille c'est vrai qu'on est
un groupe qui est plutôt jeune donc
vraiment très très content d'être à lui
verser la jeunesse justement vous misez
sur cette jeunesse
bah dis donc oui enfin déjà nous sommes
un club formateur c'est à dire que 80%
de 80% des joueurs sortent de l'une ou
l'autre école de rugby c'est à dire soit
manqué niçois de l'ancien skies rugby et
oui on s'appuie beaucoup sur ds que
disait maxime mathieu des générations
qui ont très bien marché dans les
équipements d'entente non il doit être
des joueurs qui aujourd'hui entre ont
entre 20 et 25 ans et oui on est plutôt
jeunes licenciés soit vous sentez que la
structure montant en puissance avec avec
cette fusion notamment
alors oui les joueurs se connaissent
mieux après on sort d'une fin de saison
compliquée à cause du cosei dont on a du
mal à repartir
là aussi enfin je pense qu'on est
freinée dans notre élan après il ya plus
grave que y'a plus parce que ça et mais
oui clairement aujourd'hui les joueurs
sont en équipe est très pouvait être
très voisine de celle de l'année
dernière les joueurs que ce se
connaissent maintenant bien
l'osmose entre les deux clubs s'est
parfaitement faite et
on est sur une phase ascendante c'était
clairement vous êtes actuellement 6e du
championnat de division honneur
finalement quand on regarde lui à 6,78 à
présent vous regarder plus vers le haut
que vers le bas du classement
finalement chaque saison maintenant ce
qui n'était pas forcément le cas
peut-être à il ya quelques années il ya
deux trois ans je veux dire c'est
toujours le but quand on fait du sport
on regarde plutôt vers le haut que vers
le bas je pense que c'est sinon on fait
on fait pas ce genre de sport mais oui
c'est sûr que on a une bonne dynamique
enfin moi j'en suis convaincu en tout
cas on est là pour faire le job pour
viser les tableaux quel sera l'objectif
du coup président à cette saison mais
l'objectif
l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé c'est de se
qualifier pour le championnat ile de
france c'est à dire il faut être il faut
être dans les quatre premiers
je vais dans les quatre premiers
aujourd'hui on a bâti un match en retard
dont 4/6 c'est pas on est soit un bout
de route avec une victoire à l'extérieur
après on sait qu'il ya des grosses
équipes dans la poule on a au moins un
but par ixo démange dernier iliad il
yad'autres aux équipes il a d'autres
grosses équipes dans cette poule donc
c'est je pense qu'on va avoir une poule
équilibrée
on n'est pas passé si loin que ça
l'année dernière où on avait perdu
beaucoup de matches d'un point ou deux
points
c'est année c'est jouable c'est
seulement cette année c'est dans
l'objectif
après il ya trop de trop d'équipés n'a
pas encore vu enfin je vais pas les
citer la mêlée des équipes pour nous
annonce forte qu'on n'a pas encore joué
et qui sont certainement forte juste et
en caleçon aux principaux adversaires
cette année selon ben aux voisins de
chevreuse en l'air d'avoir une belle
équipe
trois victoires en trois matches
opposeront des équipes vitry qui était
dans notre poule l'année dernière qui
nous a battus deux fois l'année dernière
mais de peu il semblerait qu aulnay sous
bois soie grise est également une belle
équipe
et puis par xo qui très clairement m'a
fait grosse impression a fait grosse
impression malgré leur défaite du
premier match contre clichy je crois
mais par ixo à une équipe
moi j'ai vu une équipe de niveau vous
donnez vous fait dire à trois
quart-temps nager contre maxime voudrais
vous confirmez ce seront les principaux
adversaires
bah pareil sauvy c'est sur son pour voir
jouer le match dimanche dernier c'était
c'était compliqué même pour nous les
gens on sentait bien que on a donné tout
ce qu'on avait même moment donné c'est
le sport aussi qu'on est plus fort que
nous il faut il faut savoir le dire
bon c'est pas démotivant du tour au
contraire je pense que c'est une bonne
opportunité aussi pour nous deux
dossiers le niveau de jeu de voir
jusqu'où on peut aller
mais oui je confirme sûre en tout cas
sur pareil exploit c'était c'était très
fort cheuvreux aussi qui est à enchaîner
trois matches avec des victoires ça a
l'air d'être plutôt solide donc il ya de
la concurrence en tout cas c'est sûr et
certain
je voulais vous parle également du coc
u19 comment vous de gérer au sein du
club de lui verser 60 18
est ce que ça vous perturbe dans votre
préparation de match assad et partir
beaucoup alors
le rugby est un des sports qui a
franchement bien d'autres qui a fait un
protocole à c'est assez clair validé par
le ministère des sports
donc on a le droit de jouer au rugby on
a le droit de jouer au rugby
ce qui est très compliqué c'est
l'absence ou la quasi absence de
vestiaire ça c'est vraiment un gros
problème à paris xe où on a eu 40
joueurs qui se sont changées sur le bord
du terrain
pas de vestiaire pas de douche les
entraînements c'est très compliqué
également d'avoir des vestiaires après
on a eu un match annulé parce qu'il y
avait des quatre co vide chez
l'adversaire
donc oui c'est perturbant et puis alors
si j'ose dire cerise sur le gâteau le
le couvre-feu à 21h à 21h normalement
c'est la plaine c'est le milieu de notre
entraînement notre équipe seniors ils
s'entraînent de 20 heures à 22 heures
donc on a on a été aussi astucieux qu'on
pouvait on avancer avancer les
entraînements mais malheureusement il ya
des joueurs qui habitent loin ou qui
travaillent tard qu'ils ne vont pas
pouvoir s'entraîner du tout ou moins
s'entraîner alors on est on est logé à
la même enseigne que tous les autres
sports et tous les autres adversaires
mais oui c'est clairement perçu au
revoir c'est très clairement car on
annonce peut-être ce n'est pas encore
fait mais sûrement demain ou après
demain un gel de déclassement et une
reprise de la compétition vers mi
janvier
est ce que ce serait une bonne solution
sûrement vous moi à titre personnel je
fais plutôt de sur une vision que tant
qu'on peut jouer essayons de jouer parce
que j'appréhende s'il ya un arrêt d'un
mois et demi des compétitions alors
après ça doit dépendre des ça va
dépendre des conditions est ce qu'on
pourra continuer à s'entraîner ou pas on
parle d'un couvre-feu à 19 heures si
c'est ça c'est la mort dans ces d'abord
les entraînements
donc si on peut facilement pour moi si
on continue à jouer
j'étais plus pour le fait pour le fait
de jouer quitte à s'entraîner un peu
moins qui tape à avoir des problèmes de
vestiaires voilà mais je sens bien que
ça de tout ça tout ça nous échapper que
toute façon on fera ce qu'on aura droit
de faire et puis voilà merci à tous les
deux en tout cas d'être passé sur ce
plateau bon courage pour la suite de la
saison et on espère que vous pourrez
jouer le plus longtemps possible en tout
cas au rugby est en tout cas vous
pourrez aller accomplir vos objectifs
pour la fin de saison
alors comme chaque semaine tv soit 118
vous propose de découvrir un sport
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur le
disc-golf une discipline hybride basé
sur les règles du golf et les clubs et
les bals sont remplacés par un frisbee
sa discipline était présenté à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines ce
week-end des images de siraga tsongo une
activité insolite à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines une session de
disc-golf était proposé gratuitement
dans la structure ce samedi 24 octobre
ce sport très populaire aux états-unis
en australie est un mélange entre
l'ultimate et le golf
on va être sur derrick très similaire à
celle du golfe avec un parcours qui va
aller de va de 4 comme aujourd'hui
panier à 18 paniers potentiellement et
l'objectif c'est d'envoyer le frisbee
dans le panier en faisant le moins de
lancers possible leur partant à chaque
fois de landreau le frisbee et ont joué
en compétition par cinq cent mille
personnes à travers le monde et 22 clubs
en france cette activité peut être
également pratiqué au niveau loisir
comme ce jour là à travers quatre trous
on est sur une activité très ludique
très convivial et accessible à tous à
partir moment effectivement où on peut
parcourir la distance entre les
différents paniers c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va être ouvert à tous
les publics un peu comme le golf
finalement après une heure de pratique
première réaction c'est intéressant de
découvrir le golf à travers le frisbee
et donc tous les enfants devront
apprécier donc du coup c'est une
activité sympathique mais tous niveaux
un petit bol dernier
à 5 ans a réussi à faire donc on est
content bien mais au bout d'un moment là
bas j'étais juste devant j'ai lancé et à
cause du vent s'est emporté j'ai pas pu
réussir
on lui doit en fait une activité en
famille on peut se balader faire preuve
d'un petit peu de la drees agréable
l'île de loisirs organisera de nouvelles
sessions de disc-golf dans les prochains
mois et notamment pendant la période
estivale un mot de boxe libinois tony
yoka va remonter assure les ring le
boxeur de 28 ans originaires de
chanteloup les vignes va affronter le
croate de 25 en pétard millas la
rencontre aura lieu pour le titre vacant
de l'union européenne des lourds le
combat tové devrait être programmée
d'ici la fin de l'année
le français partira favori les 19e
mondial alors que le croate et 51e mais
attention son adversaire a déjà remporté
deux ceintures international tony aucun
reste sur une belle victoire contre gan
duo passe dès le premier rang d'espoir
remporté son premier championnat
professionnel
il devait y avoir de la course à pied ce
week-end dans les yvelines mais la ville
de poitiers a décidé d'annuler à la
dernière minute son halloween reis ce
samedi 31 octobre dans les rues de la
commune
la raison la crise sanitaire avec locaux
vides 19 l'événement devrait être
reportée c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi très belle serait
sur tv 78
[Musique]